well this is a good one because your  first instinct when you hear the word  skunk it's probably to run away but  we've got the perfect case this is a  Dispatch Center in Indiana nugget the  skunk is actually a part-time employee  at the Dispatch Center he serves  as an emotional support skunk it's  official he has a badge number 4-2pu get  it I love it is allowed to nap at work  he's the only one of course management  says they let the Naps slide because  nugget the emotional support skunk is so  you want to let him nap you don't want  to make him angry who's going to argue  with him really it's a brave  photographer that gets up close to a  skunk for a news story by the way